[Musique]
jarry solution brouillard essayé table
l'annoncé officielle a été lu à la
télévision nationale le président a
présenté sa démission au conseil
constitutionnel le dit le communiqué et
cette décision prend effet aujourd'hui
même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la nouvelle a été accueillie par un
concert de klaxon dans les rues d'alger
la population réclamait cette démission
depuis que le président avait annoncé en
février son intention de briguer un
nouveau mandat
plus tôt aujourd'hui les algérois était
encore une fois descendus dans la rue
pour réclamer un départ rapide de ce
président qu'on dit paralysé et afone
depuis des années il avait pourtant
annoncé hier la formation d'un nouveau
gouvernement et son intention de quitter
son poste d'ici la fin du mois d'avril
mais les manifestants étaient sceptiques
nous sommes contre ce nouveau
gouvernement dit cette étudiante
nous voulons changer tout le système et
dissoudre les deux chambres du parlement
nous sommes venus pour changer
complètement le système ajoute cet
étudiant
nous leur permettrons pas de nous
tromper ni d'essayer de nous endormir
les gens au pouvoir ne sont pas
légitimes dit cet homme
il y à un conflit entre la présidence et
les militaires cela saute aux yeux de
tout le monde
métaux lourds quelques heures plus tôt
le ministère algérien de la défense
avait exigé la démission du président
immédiatement le chef de l'état major
des armées le général ahmed gaïd salah
dit qu'il n'y a plus de temps à perdre
cet ancien allié et proche du président
bouteflika affirme maintenant qu'il se
range du côté du peuple qu'il a compris
ses demandes et qu'il n'y aura pas de
retour en arrière
peu de réactions à l'étranger pour le
moment le département d'état américain
dit simplement qu'il appartient aux
algériens de fixer le cadre de la
transition politique
[Musique]
ce soir la suite des choses n'est pas
clair selon la constitution algérienne
c'est le président de la chambre haute
qui doit assumer l'intérim jusqu'à la
tenue de nouvelles élections dans les 90
jours et l'armée pourrait toutefois
désigner quelqu'un d'autre la population
algérienne reste aux aguets et va
probablement continuer de manifester
s'il va les jardins radio-canada à
montréal